colin kaepernick who has you know lots  of opinions out there about the what he  is doing taking a knee like enemy during  a national anthem what are your thoughts  I really respect your opinion what do  you think well I mean you know with  what's going on you know I'd rather see  him take a knee then stand up put his  hands up he'd get murdered so I mean my  mom my take on it is they gotta start  somewhere and if that was the starting  point I just hope people open up their  hearts to see that it's really a problem  going on and something needs to be done  for it to stop and I mean if you're  really not racist then you won't see  what he done what he's doing as a threat  to America but just addressing a problem  that we have right not a threat to the  game not a threat to America  [Applause]